Her low freak bitches.
Yeah,
and the idea that I know,
I know I lived in the city since I was 18 so I've been around gays for a quarter
century and I think of these guys I know that had been together for 10 years and
I go,
so let me get this straight,
this,
these two are going to break up according to UN evangelical person and then
they're just going to make out with some chick with blonde hair and eat her out
and like fuck her and have a boner and pray to God.
Come on.
You'd know that won't happen.
I wonder how much of homosexual behavior could be induced by molestation at an
early age though.
But yeah,
that's the million dollar question.
That seems to be a real factor.
It's not,
and this is not the nine people that are born gay,
but I think there's a spectrum and I think there's most certainly some gay acts
that are committed on young people and horrifically those people tend to on a
pretty frequent basis do the same thing to other young kids.
It's really weird in in,
in terms of like the victims becoming the victimizer.
Yeah.
I know where you're going with this.
We're walking into the elephant in the room,
but what kind of,
not even,
I mean just just talking about,
I was listening to the George to Chi interview today because they're trying to
pull up everybody now that the Milo thing is out there,
they're pulling up everybody who in any way it has condoned sex with underage
people.
And George to Kai was talking about his own experiences in camp and it was on
the stern show and he was just talking about w what he,
the way he was describing it as a positive experience with a,
a kid who was in his late teens,
I think he said it was 19 and he was like 13 somewhere in that age.
And you know,
it's absolutely child molestation.
It's absolutely illegal.
But the way he was describing it,
he was pretty much describing it as a positive experience.
Right?
Which when it's your experience,
I mean it's illegal.
The guy did something that was against the law.
But boy,
that's a weird area because it's his experience.
And he was talking about,
yeah,
well here's the deal and this is a mistake Milo made.
You have to acknowledge that what you're talking about is fucked up and horrible
and wrong,
but you just so happen to have not had a bad experience within those parameters.
Like say you were raped as a woman and you came,
right?
Uh,
which by the way happens for some strange reason.
So if you're one of those women and you're about to say that,
you have to understand that we're going into a very dangerous place right now.
And you can't say,
look,
some rapes are absolutely fabulous and women have come from them.
You have to say,
this is fucking horrible.
Rape is evil.
But I buy some weird freak of nature actually liked,
or a murderer.
I'm sure there's times when you murdered a guy and he ended up,
he was a mass murder and it was a good murder,
right?
And you go,
okay,
this,
I'm describing a murder.
I'm not condoning murderer.
But in this weird case,
it worked.
And Milo's mistake was,
he said it worked for me and then he implied that it could work for a ton of
other gays to be fucked at 13.
Well he did that,
um,
drunken peasants podcast and his take on it from a drunken peasants was
different than his take on it from mine.
And on my podcast it seemed more like he was trying to make light of something
that most likely definitely did happen to him.
The father Michael thing.
So there's two,
there's the father Michael thing and I don't know if I believe that.
I think that's,
it's a,
I've heard him say that joke a few times where he's like,
I'd never would have given such good head if it wasn't for Father Michael.
Right.
So you think that might be something like that he's constructed?
I don't believe it.
I don't know why.
That's just my gut.
And then the other thing was condoning sexual relationships with 13 year olds
and he said,
especially in the gay world,
now I know of straight guys who were a straight guy,
I'm thinking of in particular who was molested at camp.
And it was by an older gay camp counselor.
This guy thinks of that guy every day,
falls him on linkedin hoping he'll die.
He wants to murder him.
Uh,
so the problem with what Milo said is you end up normalizing this behavior and
say it's okay if in the gay world,
next thing you know,
some older gay who's at Camp Goes,
well,
this is probably a fag that I'm blowing.
Right?
So this is okay.
Yeah.
So what I say to these gays,
these 13 year old gates to go,
I would be okay with fucking a 29 year old.
I go,
well,
I'm sorry,
but we're not normalizing that because the vast,
vast majority of times it doesn't turn out well.
So No.
Yeah,
that's a very good way of putting it,
you know,
and it's,
it's really disturbed.
Well done.
The Milo thing is so odd because first of all,
I think he's got this act and let's call it an act cause part of it has got to
be an act.
He's got a wide spectrum of his personalities.
So on Bill Maher,
he can be a raging Liberace queen with pearls on dress like a woman.
I mean,
just like a woman.
Yeah.
Camper than any woman I know.
And then for the apology,
he's the conservative with the coke bottle glasses.
Yeah.
It's sorta like when a Jamaican goes back to Jamaica and they start speaking in
Patois,
like their grandmother and not necessarily lying.
It's just a wide range of use.
Yeah.
He plays it up and there is,
there's definitely a performance piece to a lot of what he does.
What's,
what's really interesting is he's very good at riling people up.
He's obviously very good at getting people upset.
And,
and in doing so,
he's created these sort of false narratives about him,
that he's a Nazi,
that he promotes genocide.
I mean,
there were so many people outside the Berkeley thing that were screaming,
calling them a Nazi and saying he's a fascist when they in fact were behaving in
very authoritarian,
fascist ways.
That's Antifa.
By the way,
you said,
I don't know what Antifa is.
That's those guys antifascist is that what Antifa stands for?
Okay.
But you're right,
they're terrorists and they use terror.
They use violence to achieve political gains,
which is terrorism and a these people,
it's not like Milo ever set or Trump even ever said anything that is remotely
close to genocide,
but those guys just go.
Anyone that wants to enforce immigration laws is a fucking Nazi.
So I need violence cause I'm trying to stop Hitler.
I'm around the first stages of Hitler,
so I'm going back in time and strangling him in his crib.
Kind of dry.
Right.
But the problem is the way they're reacting to it is the absolute wrong way to
react to someone who sang something that you don't agree with.
Oh yeah.
The the right way is to say something that you feel opposes what they're saying.
It makes more sense to debate them.
That's the beauty of free speech.
Like it has no limits.
If you want to get out there and deny the Holocaust,
you want to get out there and sexualized toddlers.
I'll go to your talk.
I want to hear it.
And then in the Q and a,
I'll shoot you down.
Well,
not,
I don't think he even should just be a Q and a.
I mean,
I think it should be real clear other there,
there should be someone and they,
we shouldn't just rely on the audience to come up with some sort of a response.
I think if you're going to have someone as controversial as Milo and you are so
opposed to it that you're willing to throw bricks through Starbucks windows and
light cop cars on fire,
there should be someone that can speak for your side,
of course,
and then you should organize some sort of a talk.
But this is setting it up the wrong way because you go,
it's like someone said to me once,
hey man,
you know,
like we were talking about martial arts flows,
black belt,
I'd fucking kick everybody's ass.
Like,
oh no,
you wouldn't.
No,
First of all,
you wouldn't because you'd have discipline and you'd realize the consequences of
that.
But second of all,
when you just kick someone's ass,
they don't,
they don't just take it like they come back with a bat or a gun or their
brother,
he started fighting.
They want to get it back and it goes back and forth and back and forth and all
conflict pretty much goes that way.
You have conflict and then someone responds to that conflict and it escalates.
So if you have this thing where you start throwing bricks through windows and
lighting cop cars on fire in stopping people from talking and hitting people
that have a make bitcoin great again,
hats and just see that girl got maced in the face by a 60 year olds.
Eventually people show up with guns.
That's what happens.
This is what happens when you keep escalating the violence.
You become a them.
You become the other,
you become the enemy and you create this polarizing atmosphere that's so intense
that no dialogue kind of fix it now because you're the enemy.
We were talking about the north versus the south.
You're,
you're talking about,
you know the,
the Protestants versus the Catholics.
You,
you,
you create this horrific environment where almost it's almost impossible to
avoid violence.
Well,
so I'm done avoiding it.
I'm taking the low road.
I'm punching them in the face.
So that's what you're doing with this outfit?
Yes.
That is really what I'm doing stuff.
But I did a talk at Nyu.
They pepper sprayed me.
Did they read,
when was this?
This was a couple of weeks ago.
What did,
what was it talk about?
I didn't even have a plan.
I was,
they know me as pro Trump or something and they,
I'm a Nazi because of that and they should,
they don't want to give a platform to free.
That's the irony of all this is they pretend that it's gotten so far.
It's beyond debate now in their world.
We are recruiting fascists for some sort of imminent genocide.
So we're like signing up the brown shirts with a form at our talks and you go
say that was possible.
Uh,
how does that work?
Like we sign you up,
then you're part of the club.
Then you come with us on the next genocide.
The fuck are you talking about?
You haven't even played it through in your mind because for these people it's a
religion.
That's why they don't want to debate.
It's like a born again.
He doesn't want a debate about the existence of God.
He's already on that side.
So what was your plan when you went there?
What did,
what did you want to talk?
I was going to say,
uh,
this Nazi that,
that you've made Milo and I out to be who wants genocide and who,
uh,
sees nonwhites is inhuman,
blah,
homophobic,
sexist,
whatever.
Uh,
first of all,
that guy should be allowed to talk if he existed,
but he doesn't exist.
Your monster is a mythical beast and you've gone to college,
you're 60 grand in debt already to fight this mythical beast who doesn't fucking
exist?
Well,
in terms of Milo,
he definitely doesn't exist.
Milo is not a Nazi.
He's definitely,
he's not promoting genocide.
And those are two things that just get trumpeted about left and right.
Exactly who is,
but Milo has said some very inflammatory things about,
and in a very generalizing way about women and about the wage gap and about all
sorts of things that he,
he designs his words and his phrases to be inflammatory.
So he gets the most response and it's been incredibly profitable.
I mean,
up until Harper Collins pulled his book deal,
he had a $250,000 book advance.
His book was number one on Amazon.
Just sheerly through controversy.
Yup.
I mean through presales and controversy.
So it's a strategy and a lot of ways and it's also a response to this really
hard stance that the far left is taking this anti anti free speech stance.
Right.
But always with these cases you go,
what exactly did he say?
I always say this to people who bitch about it.
And Coulter,
I go,
what sentence in what book is factually incorrect?
What specifically are you saying?
And with this Milo thing,
he said that often sexual relationships with 13 year olds can be beneficial for
gays.
Uh,
he has since retracted that and apologized,
but that's not enough.
And that's about as,
as egregious as it gets.
The other stuff that he says,
we all say in a joking way and then that becomes pure evil and you advocate for
this,
right?
So they,
the left is willfully ignorant of humor when it comes to Milo.
And with Trump too,
you know,
within culture is doing is very similar to what Milo is doing.
You mean their,
their merchants of outrage and that's what they're doing.
I disagree.
I think they're speaking in a hyperbolic tone.
They're flamboyant,
but that's what the charter was still there.
Yes,
there's,
there's definitely some truth,
especially with Milo that some of the things that he says,
um,
but all truth.
What,
what?
Like again,
I'm saying it right now.
What,
what did he say this factually incorrect?
Well,
there wasn't a joke,
not,
not factually incorrect,
but extremely offensive to people like the 13 year old boy comment.
Like the thing about sort of normalizing relationships between grown men and 13
year old boys.
Right.
You know,
I think a big part of why he even says that is because he's in many ways like a
natural contrarian and in many ways a guy who wants to get a rise out of people.
And by saying that he didn't feel like there's any consequences to being
outrageous in that regard.
But I think we could both agree whether or not it's factual.
In his case,
it's a fucked up thing to say.
It was a fucked up thing to say it was negligent,
which is why I apologize.
But I think the grain of truth to that and with his other statements is a lot
more than a grain,
but the grain of truth to what he was saying.
His gaze have less chastity then straights.
And if a woman is known as a slut,
she's less likely to be picked up.
And I've been sued for calling a woman a slut.
Where are you really?
Yup.
Who Sued you?
It was a long time ago.
Back in vice days.
It was in to do's and don'ts and the,
the way the law is,
it's kind of antiquated,
but it's like,
oh you called her a slut now she won't have currency in the market of marriage
cause she's known as a whore.
So we're going to punish you punitively for this sin.
Did you have to settle?
Yeah.
God dammit.
You can't even call someone a slut.
There's no word for a man.
No.
A cad.
That's a compliment.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
A cat is hilarious.
Well,
the fact that there's no equivalent for a man shows you that there's a different
standard.
And then with gays it is different to like 13 year old and an older person,
right.
If it's a girl and a 40 year old teacher,
I want to take him to the parking lot and beat him until he has a weird walks.
Weird for the rest of his life.
If it's a woman in a boy,
uh,
I don't want to murder her.
I'm grossed out 13,
especially 14 little better.
And then with gays,
uh,
well I'm not gonna make the same mistake Milo made right now.
Don't ever do it.
But if a gaze,
no one has a sled in the future,
like say a 19 year old fucks,
200 people as a woman,
no one wants to go near as a gay.
You've been around the block.
No,
there's not the same consequences for sure.
And I,
I had a bit of my act about,
I don't know if you remember this commercial,
but there was a commercial adjust for men commercial where there was a baby that
was driving a Porsche,
a baby with a beard and there was a grown woman next to the baby and the baby
has like a Tuxedo on and it's like you've always wanted the biggest bed,
his beard and the baby goes to the nightclub and a bouncer looks at him and
winks.
And I'm looking at this,
look at this commercial [inaudible] see the babies?
Yeah.
So the baby walks in just for men.
I mean I don't know what the fuck just for men if you don't know it is some
stuff that guys put in their feed when they're getting old.
So this baby's got a bottle,
he goes out to the dance floor,
there's all these girls with these tiny little skirts dancing around him and
he's like,
he's like a pimp and he's with this hot woman.
And this to me my bit was this is proof,
positive proof,
positive.
There's no sexual equality when it comes to child molesting.
Cause if you even wrote that down with the sex is reversed.
If you even wrote it down,
you're fucking going to jail.
Okay.
There's a little baby girl and she goes out to a room full of guys who are
wearing Tarzan skirts and they're all swinging dicks around her and she's got a
bottle and they're all fighting for her attention and kissing her on the cheek.
You would go to fucking jail.
But that was a commercial that aired on mainstream television.
No one cared about it.
That commercial air for years,
it's probably still on now.
And that commercial is proof positive that we have a completely different
attitude towards a grown woman who's hot as fuck and a little baby.
Yeah,
well even I was watching big with the kids the other day.
Tom Hanks is what?
Eight in that movie?
Nine and then that woman's seduces him and I guess he fucks her.
He gets a boner and I'm like,
you're raping a child.
Exactly.
Why are we watching?
And she's hot.
She's hot and he looks like a man.
So I just let it ride.
If that movie was reversed and it was a,
a young girl that all of a sudden was in a sexual woman's body and the guy was
fucking her.
She's like,
I don't know.
Are we supposed to be doing this?
You would be horrified.
You would be absolutely horrified.
These protests,
especially the things like the Milo protest,
I mean maybe now that Milo has been humiliated and it at least temporarily side
tracked or put down for a bit while he has to rebuild.
Maybe someone can come along and have reasonable dialog and do some sort of a
campus B.
I don't like it.
Why is he doing these things on campuses?
First of all,
I don't think he gets paid for most of them.
What?
My theory with Milo is a,
I think his eyesight's getting worse.
His glasses are getting thicker and thicker and he sorta going,
this is my moment to make an impact.
So he's just like,
you think he's going blind?
I think so,
yeah.
He just theorizing this.
Yeah.
He's only like 28 yeah.
But you look at him,
he's,
he just can't read English.
They're insane.
Really?
Yeah.
And they're getting thicker.
Maybe it's stress,
stress me,
his eyes worse.
Um,
I don't know.
I'm not a doctor.
I can't think it would be good.
But I think he's trying to make a maximum impact,
uh,
in a short amount of time cause you think he doesn't have much time left.
That's such a way he seems healthy
weight.
In fact,
when we were in Orlando,
we made out at the site of the,
uh,
you guys made out of the cab was Milo to offend Muslims.
Wow.
So I said,
I did a big speech about freedom and [inaudible] America.
Delicious.
I like strawberries.
Well at least he freshens breath up before I know gaze just tastes better.
I said,
fuck is lamb.
And then we made out at the site of the Orlando shooting to Muslims,
but we had armed guards and stuff.
And I said,
all right,
I want to make sure these guys are scoping out the rooms and shit.
Yes.
And he goes,
I don't care if I die,
I'll happily die for this.
I was like,
well,
I do care.
Actually.
I've got three kids.
Well,
what does,
is it Neil Ism or nihilism?
I always say it wrong.
I always say nihilism,
nihilism,
that nihilistic sort of instinct that he has.
He has a burn it all down instinct and I think he has that with his life as
well.
And I think a lot of that I'm,
I'm planning some serious bro psychologists here,
you know,
some armchair psychology from someone totally unqualified.
But you've got to attribute that to any,
at least in some ways being molested as a child.
I would imagine that his experiences that he's calling positive experiences when
he was young,
in many ways those could have potentially damaged him.
And also being young and being homosexual and being rejected,
all of those things wreck havoc.
And you,
you develop this,
fuck you,
I want to burn it down.
And this is one of the strategies that he sort of adopted that strategy to be
this guy who was very difficult for like,
he's,
he's gay.
He's um,
uh,
an English gay guy who's a right winger and mean it's,
it's so baffling to them.
They don't know what to do.
They hate it because they see blacks and gays as their little pets,
and they like putting them on the front lines and going,
look at who we're helping.
And then when one of them defects to the other side,
they become particularly outraged,
but very few defect at the level that he's defected.
Right.
I mean,
turned around and started attacking direct guy here.